on DMT some people and I'm one of them
speak in strange languages spontaneously
kempt they don't even in some cases no
they're doing it they just seem to fall
into this and it's ecstatic to do for
some reason this is just an incredibly
it's what you want to do it seems to be
the obvious thing to do to speak in this
peculiar way and at first I heard it for
years moving so fast just was like I
called it elf chatter and then I don't
know why diligent prayer or something
was able to slow it down and I found I
could do it and I went out to Hawaii
years ago and took a voice-activated
tape recorder and I spent a week I took
eight grams of mushrooms every night
nearly every night for a week and made
these recordings and what I came down
with were these recordings which people
find extremely alarming to listen to it
they hear it and they just are convinced
they're not like it's not like well it
just makes people think you're crazy
they just say you know okay so you were
sitting in a tent halfway up the
mountain all by yourself and what you
chose to do was shriek in
nor strategy for some reason and now I
still think that that the secret of the
psychedelics or the point of all this it
has to do with the language
oh you want some gloss oh yeah
okay then I'm outta here okay
glossolalia without introduction me nom
nyah
why why Watseka peeping eat the chicken
dignity if it is he my work citigroup ft
it will get Ming what unclogs if Lincoln
drop architect named Wahlburgers danke
quake quake haha quantum it'll Jimmy if
the chickabee even we get sick eating if
the new chick Oaxaca who needed a room
WPP it truth who wants a homopolymer
touch me Nick what are they well which
pool
that's his I'm out of here